so welcome to the show sir why thank you
carlos bustamante look at this look how
well we're sitting here I gotta ask you
first of all about going to Mumbai and
doing the show there's a special there
how is it has an audience there
different from anywhere in North America
it's good to be home I feel like I don't
have to do things that I have to do back
home to keep up with white people I can
just be a comfortable Brown man here
audiences are audiences you know they're
there for a comedy show so it doesn't
really matter what their ethnic makeup
is that as long as they're there to
laugh that's that's all my job is to do
when it comes to comedy and like you've
been talking to that younger audience
like they might have grown up on him to
be frank they might have grown up on you
I get a lot of that you know grew up
watching you yeah and then I look at
sometimes it's somebody but man I grew
up watching and I'm like you look my age
there's like now I'm 30 I'm like wow
you've had a rough year you know rough
30 years buddy my favorite is one know
like man I love you and they misquote
you like they'll take somebody's gonna
get a hurt real bad know like hey
somebody's getting beaten tonight and
I'm like what I thought you said you
like to me well how do you misquote that
somebody gonna get a heart feel bad
somebody I'm not gonna say who oh I
think you might know him very well
when do you know that a set is ready for
a special obviously you go into like you
know smaller clubs in practicing your
stuff and like building it that's where
you get it together and then you take it
on tour and I know when I'm getting
ready because in my head I'm like I'm
getting really bored of saying this okay
I got to record this soon otherwise I'm
going to lose the UM for the bet joke
needs it's like training for a fight you
know you don't want to peak too early
yeah and then you you know you get to
the thing knew you've got no energy yeah
so you gotta you set the time and then
you pace yourself so that when you get
to the chute that you it's the last I'm
gonna go whack and you just hit it when
I was boxing I broke my nose I shouldn't
be able to move it around and double
click and order stuff Amazon from your
face
[Applause]
[Music]
you